[Music]  last night during the Giants Cowboys  game Ryan Seacrest promoted his new show  millions second quiz this is his new  show  here's that works he recruited his first  contestant by sending a reporter out to  a person's home in the Dallas area and  everything unfolded right there on  television it's pretty cool take a look  every night we're gonna surprise someone  in America who's been playing the msq  app well and fly them here to compete in  the show the very next night we call  those people line jumpers and earlier  tonight we surprised our very first one  take a look okay we're gonna surprise  our very first line jumper his name is  Lee Milner Lee are you in there Oh God  get the hell off the property thank you  very much mark and you can watch lead  plate in the main second quiz tomorrow  it should tell people ahead of time  they're coming